and within
heaven how do we picture it to ourselves
this is where you know a little
digression could be useful
i've often said to my classes if you
think about heaven the way that that it
gets depicted in cartoons
it looks like an incredibly boring place
that really nobody would want to go to
except for people who are desperate for
living on or people who really like
sitting around in clouds with harps and
you know wings and halos and all that
other sort of sort of accoutrements i
was going to say nonsense but
you know maybe some people believe in
that sort of thing um heaven can be
understood in much more robust ways
and in you know
in christianity which is really what
hegel's focusing on here in the west
depictions of heaven really were quite
well worked out you could think of you
know dante's divine comedy as an example
or all the great iconography of the
divine liturgy taking
place in heaven or all these depictions
within writings of theologians about
what heaven is going to be like they're
they're none of that namby pamby stuff
it's all a depiction of
being with other people
and and being able to truly be with
other people you know where your wills
aren't um
contradicting each other because you're
all willing
you know things that are harmonious so
he says here the departed self must
unite with its universality
must
it says if consciousness
self-consciousness reason and spirit
belong to self-knowing spirit in general
similarly
the specific shapes which were
specifically developed within
consciousness self-consciousness reason
and spirit belong to specific shapes of
self-knowing spirit so you know nothing
really that surprising
in there at each of the the points you
know we can call them
gestalts we can call them dynamics and
this kind of answers the question of
well what good is the the phenomenology
given that like history didn't end as
hegel was going to claim and some of the
other things might seem to be kind of
kind of arbitrary at times well each of
them is
a
shape and a way in which spirit is
actual within the world so it's worth
studying them and you know there's a bit
of a side note but
here hegel is also
in a way addressing the question of why
should we do
comparative religion
and you know why should we study if
there is some sort of consummate
religion that we're going to talk about
as hegel does think why should we study
all this previous stuff should it be a
triumphal you know well in the beginning
there were the animists and then there
were you know these polytheists and then
we got to henotheism and then we got to
you know monotheism and that was really
great and then it was revealed in
different ways you know first judaism
and then christianity well islam
happened afterwards but we're not going
to worry about that or let alone sikhism
and you know this sort of like
i use the word triumphalistic it means
where you're saying the religious
comportment and understanding that we
have this is the best all the other
stuff is leading up to it or veering off
from it and it's it's there's a nice
developmental picture there
we can also do comparative religion in
other ways and this is not exactly what
hegel is is advocating he is you know
saying christianity and specifically
protestant christianity uh is you know
at the apex of development um and and to
be honest his treatment of other
religions is kind of sketchy um but
there's there's possibilities for
something like a hegelian
against hegel comparative treatment of
things where we would look at each
religion as being a way in which spirit
has
in some way manifested itself and we
could still preserve a higher and lower
or you know
development thing we would just say well
there isn't just only one single
developmental path all right so
digression ended back to this
so he says
so coming back to this what does this
notion
of religion
give us well he says religion here is to
begin with immediate
immediate meaning unmediated right or
mittelbach so
we have to sketch out the mediations and
as a matter of fact this is a little bit
of a digression but
when hegel talks about something being
immediate
by now you know okay there's always more
to the story so there's there's really
two sides to this that work together
part of it is uncovering the structures
where there is mediation going on where
something is not so
cut and dried as it appears at the
beginning but like i said there's more
to the story there's other things
happening and now we make those evident
the other thing is sometimes we
introduce mediation as well so as the
phenomenologist we can be witnessing
mediation we can also be as the
phenomenologist watching the agency
seeing somebody introduce
mediation and these play off of each
other and so this is going to be quite
quite important
you